taipei is a pretty typical Asian
metropolis some areas are reminiscent of
Tokyo and the endless lanes of cars
could just as soon be in Shanghai but
gomen Ling is happy that his factories
in the countryside an hour's drive south
of Taipei 25 years ago when we were
searching the production site we were
here looking around all rice field only
just a few private houses go mingling
heads the Taiwanese factory of German
family owned company hartenberg we are
supplying to the comments like this one
we are supplying past four head on a
ceiling for Chung liner like this look
there the filter system needs efficiency
to keep the compartment cream along with
German car makers the company also
supplies leading Asian manufacturers and
they often come to Lin and his German
colleagues with special requests the one
is especially focus on Alexis they
explore a sound absorption a very high
quality of the sound absorption for the
head of the Taiwanese operations that
will cause a few sleepless nights Lin
has to deliver an even higher quality
than what's requested that's the only
way the company can assert itself in a
highly competitive market the raw
material for the nonwoven fabric is made
of 50% recycled plastic bottles
sustainability has a big appeal in Asia
and so do appearances
inspiration product because it's very
unique
no single single single sperm it is the
same
by the Poggi space table a very uniform
the boss himself encourages the 100
employees of the factory in Taiyuan to
maintain this high standard of quality
workers get four years of intensive
training before they're allowed to
supervise a shift I'm very satisfied my
job is secure management treats us
fairly and most importantly my home is
nearby an ordinary worker here earns the
equivalent of twenty five thousand euros
a year that's a decent income for a
family in the countryside where the cost
of living is around fifteen thousand
euros part of that income is spent on
good food eating well is important in
Taiwan the main topic at the table isn't
sales but the German on the team
Daniel Miller has just married a
Taiwanese woman Daniel Miller would
rather talk about Taiwan than about his
private life Taiwan has several
advantages as a location the employees
are very loyal we have a few employees
who've been with us since the company
was founded over 20 years ago the
engineers are well educated and they
also speak Chinese which makes access to
the major Chinese market easier but
unlike the People's Republic of China
Taiwan has very strict patent laws which
prevent a lot of copying of ideas and
has allowed Freudenberg to remain the
market leader in Asia with its nonwoven
fabric but the car making industry isn't
enough as customers so the company also
makes support materials for carpets and
it's fabric is used by companies like
Adidas and Timberland for their shoes
almost half of the fabric gets shipped
to mainland China where it is processed
further but gumming Lin has his sights
set on getting a toehold in India
unfortunately Indian markets they're not
yet afford to pay for the high prices
city today but I believe this will come
very soon in the near future in
anticipation of this he's expanding the
production facilities in Taiwan the
expansion will cost 35 million euros
hardened Berg's biggest investment in
Taiwan to date